R-rated films are supposed to push your
buttons. With freedom to deliver language,
blood, nudity, and drug use, you can
provide lots of provocative material.
In some instances, though, R-rated movies use
the creative freedom of their rating for less
savory purposes. These are
the films that go too far.
Every generation gets their own take on the
classic story The Most Dangerous Game, and
this generation's incarnation came with The Hunt.
This Craig Zobel film concerns a group of people
who wake up and find out they're being hunted
for sport, like any version of this tale does.
The twist this time, though, was the story
got filtered through the modern-day political
zeitgeist, with the hunters being left-leaning
"elites," while the victims were coded as
conservatives. On paper, it's easy to see how the
project received a green-light as something that,
in the vein of Team America: World Police, could
generate political discourse while drumming up
ticket sales from moviegoers who wanted to be
part of the conversation and the dark humor.
However, the marketing for The Hunt
inspired a wave of unforeseen controversy,
largely from right-leaning news organizations.
It even garnered an implied response from
former President Donald Trump, who accused
Hollywood of merely trying to stir up violence
The cause of all the brouhaha was that
many saw The Hunt as endorsing
violence against conservatives,
though this seemed to ignore how the conservative
characters were the heroes of the movie.
Still, the uproar over The Hunt had a sizable
impact and inspired the film to get delayed a
whole six months. When it came time for
this generation's Most Dangerous Game,
perhaps the filmmakers tried
to push a few too many buttons.
R-rated comedies can sometimes draw flack
for getting too racy with certain jokes,
but The Interview inspired a whole other level
of vitriol. The film about two goofballs getting
pressed into assassinating Kim Jong-un
drew negative responses from North Korea,
especially a scene depicting
the leader's gruesome death.
In fact, the film was so controversial that
it inspired a hack, apparently stemming from
North Korea, that leaked countless pieces
of sensitive information, all stemming from
distributor Sony Pictures. Things got even
crazier when the hackers eventually graduated
to threatening extreme violence against
movie theaters that screened The Interview.
The consequences of the film's provocative
humor were swift. By mid-December,
the movie's theatrical release was largely
canned, but that wasn't the end of The Interview.
On the contrary, the movie continued to inspire
widespread discussion on how to respond when
violent threats are made against artists. In the
years since its release, The Interview actor and
co-director Seth Rogen has been upfront
on what a grueling experience it all was.
Rogen said to CinemaBlend,
"Truthfully, after 'The Interview,'
[co-director Evan Goldberg and I]
were a little traumatized, I think."
Like many of Rogen's comedies, The
Interview was something that could
provoke laughs but was also meant to push buttons,
but nobody could've expected the outsized and
unprecedented response its material received.
The anthology comedy Movie 43 provides more
stars than there are in the heavens across
its various individual segments.
Whereas wall-to-wall crudeness in
other comedies can help unearth some
kind of deeper truth about humanity,
Movie 43 is now widely regarded as one of the
worst comedies to ever hit theater screens.
The participation of movie stars ranging from
Hugh Jackman to Richard Gere to Emma Stone
couldn't help elevate the film. The only
conversation drummed up by this box office dud
was a handful of horrific moments that showed the
film's desperation to wring yuks from moviegoers.
Movie 43 employed yellowface, incest, and a
closing sequence largely focused on physical abuse
being hurled at a character played by
Elizabeth Banks. Movie 43 embraced the
idea of overloading the viewer on "shocking"
material. Though the movie pushed the boundaries
of what the R-rating would allow, Movie
43 was hollow vulgarity to its very core.
Released in 2011, The Hangover Part II drew
some heavy criticism for going way too far
in its attempts to be funny. For example, many
people were outraged when the character of Stu
learns that he slept with a transgender woman.
“We didn’t get married, did we?”
“Of course not! We just had some
fun in the chardonnay room!”
The depiction of this revelation as being
"disgusting" was correctly labeled by many
as an example of bro comedies using blatant
transphobia as a substitute for actual comedy.
Garnering even more media attention at the time
was a photo in the end credits. The image parodies
an actual photo taken in the Vietnam War of a
South Vietnamese general executing a prisoner.
The moment was dubbed by
critics like Roger Ebert as,
"A desecration of one of [...] the most
famous photos to come out of the Vietnam War."
Here, fans were disappointed that a movie
that was all about shock value crossed
over from providing adult-skewing
gags into outright disrespect.
Zack and Miri Make a Porno is actually a sweet
movie when you get right down to it — one about
lifelong best friends who may actually
have romantic feelings for one another.
However, the fact that it had
the word "porno" in its title
meant the film already rubbed
some moviegoers the wrong way.
This was especially true in the movie's marketing,
which kicked off with a poster that proved so
suggestive that it ended up getting banned from
being shown in movie theaters. Sometimes, a movie
that stirs up this much controversy can ride
all the publicity to sizable box office success.
Unfortunately, none of these marketing troubles
inspired much interest from moviegoers.
Released at the very end of October 2008,
Zack and Miri Make a Porno ended up
sinking without a trace at the box office.
The Kevin Smith comedy, despite
featuring raunchy scenes like
Justin Long as an adult film star listing
off the titles of movies he's appeared in,
is ultimately a film that wants
to tug at your heartstrings.
Too bad its marketing garnered a reputation for
being all the wrong kinds of boundary-pushing.
Released in 2007, The Hills Have Eyes 2
is the kind of schlocky horror B-movie
that audiences tend to watch
because of its tasteless material.
Graphic violence, especially,
is the forte of this subgenre.
However, this particular horror sequel used its
sensibilities not to depict over-the-top violence,
but to continue a long tradition of using
sexual assault in a throwaway manner. The
Hills Have Eyes 2 centers much of its
plot on the prospect of deformed mutants
capturing human women for the
purposes of forced breeding.
The movie's emphasis on this element is made
apparent in an opening scene, one depicting an
unnamed woman trapped in the mutants' basement
solely so she can breed children. Before she can
establish even the barest personality, she's
slaughtered after birthing a stillborn baby.
Critics like Scott Tobias took The Hills Have Eyes
2 to task for resorting to such a
shallow depiction of sexual assault,
as well as for not giving any of the women
in the film basic character development.
While some grindhouse movies like Abel Ferrara's
Ms. 45 have garnered praise for using grimy
exploitation cinema to thoughtfully explore
the perspective of a sexual assault survivor,
the tactless treatment of sexual assault in
The Hills Have Eyes 2 is just plain appalling.
The 2007 Uwe Boll movie Postal opens with
a sequence depicting Flight 11 just moments
before it hit the North Tower, beginning the 9/11
terrorist attacks. In this version of the event,
the two hijackers piloting the plane decide to
abort the mission... only for the passengers to
break into the cockpit and inadvertently
cause the plane to crash into the tower.
A sequence like this was always meant
to establish the tasteless - and,
if the general critical reception is any
indicator, humorless - aesthetic of the
movie ahead. But the film's opening gag was
perceived by many as way too provocative,
to the point that one of its actors believed
it cost the film its commercial potential.
In the book My Year of Flops by Nathan
Rabin , performer Dave Foley remarked,
"I think that crashing a plane into the Twin
Towers at the start of the film hurt it."
Postal, like its video game source
material, wanted to shock and offend,
but it seems that it went above and beyond
the call of duty in its opening sequence,
which took things from vulgar
comedy to just plain vulgar.
This Cuba Gooding Jr. and Horatio Sanz story
concerns two men who enlist in a singles cruise,
only to discover it's exclusively
for gay men. They then pose as
gay while trying to get closer
to women who work on the boat.
The comedy is full of jokes about straight men
being terrified of the very presence of gay people
and how "gross" the thought of two dudes
kissing is. Critics savaged the film for
its rampant homophobia, though many writers
also slammed the movie for being too tedious.
Rita Kempley of The Washington Post, for
example, remarked that the tired and familiar
attempts at comedy were just as insulting as
the rampant gay panic material, adding that,
"It's time many of the movie's more offensive
gags […] went back into the closet."
Few films of the 1990s were as
controversial as Natural Born Killers,
the tale of murderous lovers Mickey and Mallory,
played by Woody Harrelson and Juliette Lewis.
Intended by writer and director Oliver
Stone as a condemnation of the heavy
presence of violence in the media, the general
response to the movie is still divided today
over whether or not the film
achieved its intended goals.
Critic Janet Maslin, for instance,
observed that the movie seems to
be more in love with graphic
violence than critical of it.
Maslin observed,
"While 'Natural Born Killers' affects occasional
disgust at the lurid world of Mickey and Mallory,
it more often seems enamored
of their exhilarating freedom."
Critics who interpreted the film as being
more of a love letter to this kind of
behavior saw Natural Born Killers as a lot of
ultra-violent noise without much of a purpose.
Similarly, much has been written about how
the film's treatment of indigenous cultures
is almost as stomach-churning as its
most gruesome instance of violence.
With this 1994 film, Stone meant to make
something that inspired a reaction in people.
He succeeded, but unfortunately, it
inspired a whole lot of critiques that
Stone had made something as indulgent as the
elements of society he intended to condemn.
“You’ll never understand, Wayne.
You and me? We’re not even the same
species. I used to be you, but I’ve evolved.”
Revenge of the Nerds has often been seen
as a film championing the downtrodden,
a comedic form of voyeurism wherein the oppressed
could live out their greatest fantasies.
Now for many, Revenge of the Nerds
is seen as trivializing rape culture.
This is most apparent in an infamous
sequence where the character of Lewis
pretends to be the jock Stan so he can sleep
with the quarterback's girlfriend, Betty.
It's meant to be a cheer-worthy
sequence in the movie itself,
but it registers to many now as
an endorsement of sexual assault.
Director Jeff Kanew himself has recently expressed
regret over ever including the scene in the film.
In 2019, Kanew told GQ,
"I've heard [criticism] a lot this year
because of the #MeToo movement. [...] At
the time, it was considered sort of
a switch. [...] It's not excusable.
If it were my daughter, I
probably wouldn't like it."
The R-rated events of Revenge of the Nerds were
intended to be seen as conventional escapism
but it's apparent to many now that the
movie is more insidious than humorous.
In his voyage up the river to find Marlon Brando's
Colonel Kurtz, Martin Sheen's Captain Willard sees
a wide array of horrific and unforgettable sights
that lay the horrors of the Vietnam War bare.
Unfortunately, viewers are also exposed
to a terrible sight late in the film.
For a climactic scene involving a ritual performed
by an Ifugao tribe, a water buffalo is killed
on-screen. This was apparently a real-life
practice that was already underway before
cameras started rolling, with director Francis
Ford Coppola filming the ritual as it occurred.
While intended to be a visual
parallel to Willard's plan to
assassinate Kurtz with a machete, the
sight of an animal killed on-screen
is jarring enough to render that
thematic undercurrent irrelevant.
Decades after the film's release,
Coppola has stood by the scene,
reaffirming that he was merely
documenting reality itself.
Coppola said to USA Today,
"I did not direct it or anything,
that was the way they do it."
To prove his point, Coppola made sure to
emphasize that he refused to have an extra
water buffalo around to kill in case extra takes
were needed. Despite Coppola's statements, this
scene of animal cruelty stands out in Apocalypse
Now as horrifying for all the wrong reasons.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.